let's get right to it we were talking
about this on the little two minute tv
only stub on the way in the memo that
came
out last night from commissioner roger
goodell to all 32 teams now look
yesterday sims and i were talking about
the draft and during a break i contacted
brian mccarthy the league office and i
said look i'm convinced the draft is
going forward tell me if i'm wrong and
he provided on the record statement the
draft will proceed as scheduled so we
knew yesterday morning the draft will
proceed as scheduled last night if there
was anyone who was doubting if there was
anyone who was questioning roger goodell
made it abundantly clear in a memo that
was sent to all teams and that was
released to multiple members of the
media the draft will proceed as
scheduled on april 23rd through april
25th period exclamation point end of
discussion peter your reaction to the
decision to go forward when there were
multiple general managers including
mickey loomis on your podcast pushing
back against the idea of proceeding on
the 23rd of april and arguing for a
delay in the draft
well i've tried to put myself in roger
goodell's shoes
since i read that memo last night mike
and i think
um
you know
just my total gut feeling and and some
informed feeling
about each side is that roger goodell
totally understands
the the people who say this is a tone
deaf remark he or tone deaf uh situation
where
they believe that
uh he or he understands how people
believe that this is you know tone-deaf
that he should be delaying the draft out
of respect to what's going on in this
country
but i think the other part of it is what
we saw last week during free agency how
many emails did i get to my columns
saying geez thank you
uh for continuing to do this because i
like everybody else was thinking boy
this what a useless thing that we're
doing with what's going on in our
country i think people need something
and i think roger goodell and the owners
of this league not only are trying to
capitalize on being the only game in
town mike but i also think that they
believe that they are providing some
help to the united states and to the
people who love football who have
nothing else to concentrate on
yeah it's one of those rare situations
where your own self-interest mesh with
everyone else's interest you can come
off as altruistic while at the same time
you're lining your pocket with a process
that is going to result in the highest
ratings they've ever had for the draft
because there's nothing else going on
and people are going to look forward to
it i'm looking forward to it millions
will be looking forward to it because it
gives us a common shared experience at a
time when nothing seems normal we know
the draft is going to go forward now
it's going to be a very abnormal tv
production but that's okay it gives us
something that we can all gather around
that feels like it's real sports even
though it isn't real sports and here's
the money quote from the the memo and
there are several important quotes in
there we'll be talking about today
goodell writes to all teams i have
personally discussed this matter with
many other owners club executives and
coaches there's widespread support for
the management council executive
committee's conclusion to go forward
everyone recognizes that public health
conditions are highly uncertain and
there is no assurance that we can select
a different date and be confident that
conditions will be significantly more
favorable than they are today look this
ultimately was the same argument that i
think was the only argument the best
argument for going forward last week
with free agency it's bad now who knows
when it's going to be better when are
you going to be able to do the draft if
you don't do it on april 23rd when will
it be better can you do a draft in july
or august with football season looming
so i understand that side of it that if
we delay it just like with free agency
when will there be the right time to do
it things are going to get worse before
they get better let's just go ahead and
do it now i understand that argument
peter uh at a time when we really don't
know when that window would open and it
would be the right time for this to go
forward
yeah and mike last week i in my column
on monday so this would have been 11
days ago
i wrote uh and quoted two general
managers anonymously
who basically said this is insane what
we're doing do we have any we're tone
deaf we don't see what's going on in the
country
and yet over the next i'd say three or
four days
maybe five days culminating with all the
brady stuff late in the week
uh all of that stuff i think uh was
fodder for you for me for everybody who
covers the game and
for all the people honestly mike
i got a lot of mail to my column
uh in the last week plus
about this topic
and i did not get one email not one out
of maybe 50
that said essentially
i mean the nfl
should have postponed free agency and
again obviously those are football fans
writing to me i get it but i get my
share of of of hateful emails as well as
as well as probably most people in the
business do
so i really think that that is one of
the big reasons why the nfl is going
ahead with this
not only to keep the trains running
let's go
but to basically say we're going to be
able to give something to this country
that uh that we feel like will be good
for the country hey honestly mike adam
schefter had a great idea on espn i
thought and he said
the nfl really should have one round a
day
and should make every issue that's a
horrible idea it's a horrible idea yes
horrible idea why horrible idea because
nobody gives a crap after round two
or after let's say after round three
that last day around four through seven
is interminable even as we are craving
something real round four round five
round six
seven does no nobody cares
it gets people like todd mcshea
and daniel jeremiah and all those people
to sit up there with rich eisen and trey
wingo and all those people and just talk
about the nfl
you know and have guys on zoom video
conferencing or whatever it is for those
days and i'm not saying they absolutely
should do it but the nfl could stretch
this out more than it already is
and i think they'd still get a lot of a
lot of viewers and they still get a lot
of people who would be interested in the
draft
and you raise an interesting point
i think unintentionally as to how that
process is going to unfold there isn't
going to be a stage there isn't going to
be a desk with three or four people and
if they're there they're going to be
sitting at opposite ends of it like the
big giant table in the mansion where
you've you know passed there's no you
gotta walk 50 people on the desk no that
that will not happen this time around
and it's it's going to be a bunch of
people by zoom video conference it's
going to be a bunch of people wearing
air pods while they talk on tv it's
going to be technologically the
equivalent of spinning 50 plates because
they're going to be bringing all these
people in remotely from their homes
whatever technology they're using that's
how this thing is going to come off
which is going to make it so much more
different but also so much more
compelling and
look the nfl understands that there is
value to the nation right now but but
also value to the nfl it will be the
only thing that is on the calendar for
april so we're going to talk about it
for the next three weeks in six days
we're going to get get ourselves focused
on that event and i think it's going to
draw in peter some casual fans that
otherwise only pay attention to the nfl
on super bowl sunday because it's
something it's going to be a shared
experience that unites everyone at a
time when we all have kind of hunkered
down in our own little worlds and are
focusing on whatever show we're
streaming whatever you know whatever had
the news
this is something that's going to be a
break from all of the negative that we
all can experience at the same time it's
going to kind of feel like a real
sporting event and that's why i think
the ratings whatever the the high water
mark has been in the past this is going
to blow past it because of what's
currently going on so yes it's going to
help us but it's also going to help the
nfl
mike i also think that and again we're
getting way too deep into the weeds
probably for you know for everything
that's going on but one of the things
that i think the nfl is going to have to
think about with this draft because it's
going to be tremendously inconvenient
the technology is just not the
technology is going to be fine but
you're not going to be able to have the
contact and the conversations that you'd
normally have before a draft so my
feeling is that the nfl one of the
things they should do is consider
stretching out the time probably in both
the first and second rounds
um to be able to give coaches more of a
chance to pick up the phone instead of
the scout being in the same room you
know he might be on the phone or he
might be
you know on skype or something like that
you might even be in the next room i
don't know but it's not going to be the
same thing it's not going to be as
convenient as it always was so i think
those are the kind of things now that
everybody knows it's going to happen on
april 23rd i think those are the kind of
things the mechanical things that the
nfl's got to think about
well any suggestions that anyone with
any team would like to make along those
lines it is very important that those
suggestions be made directly and
exclusively to the league office do not
talk to peter king about it do not talk
to me about it unless you get yourself
in trouble here's the line from the next
to the last paragraph of the memo that
roger goodell sent last night the
management council executive committee
was also clear and i share the
committee's view that public discussion
of issues relating to the draft serves
no useful purpose and is grounds for
disciplinary action that's any
discussion
positive negative
neutral if you talk about any of the
issues relating to the draft and you
work for a team or you work for the
league you are going to be
punished i've heard from people who are
apoplectic now i don't know can you get
punished for talking about your
disagreement with the fact that you can
get punished for talking about the draft
i don't know how how far down that
rabbit hole roger goodell is going to go
but the idea that the hammer can fall on
anyone who says anything publicly about
the decision to go forward with the
draft that is some heavy-handed stuff
peter
yeah you know mike i'm sure you have the
the sort of same relationship with some
people around the league that you
probably woke up this morning and had a
few text messages
that basically said essentially
uh and i'll paraphrase
what country are we living in
um you know and what i think is
is a little odd about this
uh when i read that memo last night that
just really stuck out to me because
remember during ray rice
where everybody and his brother and his
sister
players and and everything are throwing
molotov cocktails at roger goodell
just absolutely obliterating roger
goodell
and to the best of my knowledge nobody
ever got disciplined for those things
and now let's say we fast forward it one
week
and let's say mickey loomis
this coming week the general manager of
the saints who is you referred to on my
podcast this week said that he thought
the draft should be delayed there were
just too many problems that are going to
prevent a real legitimate
draft where you have all the information
that you need and he said i think the
draft should be delayed the difference
between him saying that
on wednesday of this week versus on
wednesday of next week might be about
250 000
and so in my opinion
i think i'd feel frustrated if i were
uh front office people in the nfl
knowing that and mike here's one other
thing i would tell you and i don't know
what's happened to you in the last few
days
but i can tell you in the last say 10
days
you know i've covered this league for 36
years
and in the last 10 days
i can't get most of the people i
normally get to talk to me
off the record about the draft and about
everything else going on around the
league it's either non-return texts or
phone calls or i'll talk to you in a few
weeks and it's just
it's a little weird what's going on out
there i think there's no question that
front offices have gotten the message
well and it's funny you mentioned the
text messages that we woke up to the the
people in the league
know who the agitators and the
troublemakers are and
they they know how they know how to push
my buttons and get me cranked up and
i've been exercising as much restraint
as i possibly can i'm trying to be the
anti-woody woodpecker in this situation
and realize
that that uh people who would like to
unleash publicly and can't are going to
try to push our buttons to get us to do
it i'll share with you one text i got
last night thank god for the first
amendment i'll sleep better tonight that
was a reaction obviously to the thou
shalt not discuss any issues relating to
the draft going forward on april 23 to
april 25. and look
i i kind of want
that that that woody woodpecker
troublemaker inside of me peter kind of
wants to see someone test it to see if
the nfl actually would
discipline someone
for
raising legitimate concerns i mean every
workplace in the country has
whistleblower protections where if
someone speaks up about something that
they disagree with they can't be thrown
out the door they can't be punished in
some way and it would be very very
intriguing to see if the nfl would
actually go through with it if a gm
would decide to go on the record today
or a head coach or an owner and say it's
wrong to go forward on april 23rd and
it's wrong to tell people they can't
express that dissent
yeah you know i'm not as i said a minute
ago mike i'm not even sure it's wrong to
go forward i i can't i can say there's
no question about it i'm writing next
week about a guy who ended this year
heard in college didn't go to the
combine and is not going to have any
exposure to any team other than by
facetime and is like morose about the
whole thing and i think one of the
things that we're seeing right now is
that this is going to be and not just
technologically
this is going to be
one of the weirdest drafts
uh that we've ever covered you know it's
almost like i think daniel jeremiah said
something great in my column the other
day and he said
with what we're seeing right now if the
draft goes on as scheduled basically
we're going to see teams
hitting a lot more singles than going
for triples especially later in the
draft in other words playing it safe
through the draft because they would
rather go with the guy who at least
they've looked face to face who they
like his tape
and they've talked to face to face for
15 minutes in indianapolis at the very
least now they seem to have somewhat of
an idea of who this guy is so but i can
tell you that a lot of teams are
extremely uncomfortable with this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports